als er den ölstand seines autos messen
wollte schnitt er sich in den finger so
infizierte er sich mit einem
gefährlichen keim weil der mann seinen
namen nicht nennen will
nennen wir ihn einst schäfer ich hatte
zuerst gedacht das war auch noch an
einem wochenende an einem
samstagnachmittag ist nicht so schlimm
beachte mal nicht zuerst verhielt sich
die wunde auch ganz normal im lauf des
samstags und auch in der nacht von
samstag auf sonntag wurde das
schmerzgefühl in meiner rechten hand
eigentlich von stunde zu stunde stärker
dieses pochende entzündungs gefühl nahm
aus so stark zu dass ich eigentlich auch
nicht mehr schlafen konnte schäfer fährt
ins krankenhaus dort wird er sofort
operiert ein multiresistenter keime mrsa
wird auch seiner haut entdeckte dann
praktisch die gesamte hand hohle hand
praktisch eröffnet bisher ist der zünder
und die kann sich sehr schnell wirklich
an entlang dieser bindegewebe gesetzten
dann praktisch bis zum oberarm
lymphknoten bis hin zum herzen
ausbreiten und wenn man gar nicht
adäquat und sofort reagiert patienten
haben wir allerdings auch extreme
schmerzen dann kann sich das eben sehr
sehr dramatisch entwickeln heute
erinnern nur noch ein pflaster an die
infektion schäfer hatte glück denn
multiresistente keime sind eine der
größten gefahren nicht nur für kranke
menschen gegen sie hilft oft kein
antibiotikum mehr
nach schätzungen der europäischen
seuchenschutzbehörde starben 2009 10 in
europa bis zu 33.000 menschen durch
multiresistente keime in den vorjahren
waren es deutlich weniger
multiresistente keime gibt es vor allen
dingen in krankenhäuser falsche und zu
häufige verordnung von antibiotika
doch auch die industrielle tierhaltung
ist ein problem vor allem die
geflügelmast weil viele tiere auf engem
raum gehalten werden können einzelne
kranke nicht behandelt werden sondern
nur alle in einer halle
zwar ist der verbrauch von antibiotika
in der tierhaltung insgesamt in den
vergangenen jahren um fast 50 prozent
zurückgegangen bei der hähnchenmast ist
das nicht so gerd ludwig meier ist
niedergelassener arzt und warnt vor der
wachsenden gefahr durch multiresistente
keime und den einsatz von antibiotika in
der massentierhaltung die resistenzen
werden dramatisch zunehmen potenzial ist
es so dass jede kleinste wunde zum tode
führen kann durch eine sepsis
blutvergiftung weil kreimer überall
und wenn keine antibiotika mehr wirksam
sind da können wir sie nicht bekämpfen
im august und september wurde bei den
discountern aldi nord und lidl in fünf
europäischen ländern hähnchenfleisch
gekauft von der umweltorganisation
germanwatch die fleischproben gingen ans
institut für medizinische mikrobiologie
der universität bochum und wurden dort
untersucht
[Musik]
ein wichtiges ergebnis ist dass über die
hälfte aller proben mit resistenten
bakterien verunreinigt war
bakterien also die gegen antibiotika
unempfindlich sind und was zur folge hat
dass man möglicherweise nicht mehr gut
therapiert werden kann
die meisten keime hatte hähnchenfleisch
vom discounter in deutschland und polen
59 prozent der proben trugen
multiresistente keime in frankreich 45
prozent in den niederlanden 25 prozent
in deutschland und polen fand sich dazu
in 25 prozent der fleisch pakete der
gefährliche krankenhauskeim mrsa mrsa
sind deswegen ein besonderes ergebnis
weil sie relativ selten ansonsten auf
hähnchen proben gefunden kann er marissa
ist ja ein bekannter multiresistente
schwer zu therapieren da kein der
wundinfektion verursachen kann aber auch
an lungenentzündungen
auffallend häufig finden sich mrsa keime
bei produkten der deutschen phw gruppe
zu der auch die marke wiesenhof gehört
hersteller und discounter weisen darauf
hin geflügelfleisch ist vor dem essen
komplett durch zu garen das problem beim
schneiden und der verarbeitung der ruhe
hähnchenteile können keime sowohl an den
händen als auch an der unterlage haften
bleiben und wenn sie auf diesem
schneidbrett dann hinterher salat
schneiden dann gerät dieses bakterium
direkt in die nahrung und sie nehmen das
auf und können sich so mit resistenten
bakterien infizieren nachfrage bei den
discountern die verweisen auf ihre hohen
qualitätsstandards für die produktion
seien die hersteller verantwortlich
im übrigen sei auch der verbraucher in
der pflicht so schreibt aldi nord zitat
bitte küchenhygiene hinweise beachten
geflügelfleisch ist nicht zum verzehr
geeignet
doch die untersuchung von germanwatch
hat noch ein ergebnis jedes dritte
untersuchte hähnchen war mit keimen
belastet die auch gegen sogenannte
reserve antibiotika resistent sind
antibiotika die eigentlich dem menschen
vorbehalten sein sollten unsere
untersuchung zeigt in der
massentierhaltung werden routiniert an
die börse kam es braucht auch
reserveantibiotika die wirtschaft hat
sich entschieden sie möchte billiger
werden sie möchte nicht besser werden
die wissenschaft sagt schon lange hier
muss nachgebessert werden
verantwortlich dafür
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin julia
klöckner mit der deutschen
geflügelwirtschaft wollte sie über
weniger antibiotika einsatz in ställen
verhandeln frontal21 liegen vertrauliche
gespräch von merkel vor
darin heißt es dass die
geflügelwirtschaft in bezug auf die
forderung nach einer änderung von
produktion und haltungssysteme nicht
gesprächsbereit sei die stufe auf eine
wand also das ganze war nicht sehr
dynamisch nach vorne lösungsorientiert
um es kurz zu sagen und das will ich
wirklich eine denn wenn es resistenzen
selbst bei reserve antibiotika gibt und
reserve antibiotika sind die antibiotika
die da sind wenn es nichts anderes mehr
gibt dann ist das fatal nachfrage beim
zentralverband der deutschen
geflügelwirtschaft der versicherte in
den vergangenen jahren sei der einsatz
von antibiotika in der tiermast spürbar
gesenkt worden schriftlich heißt es
zitat
trotz aller minimierung strategien wird
eine kontinuierliche weitere reduzierung
bis auf null aber nicht möglich sein
[Musik]
die eu kommission will den einsatz von
antibiotika in der landwirtschaft stark
reduzieren ab 2021 sollen einige
wirkstoffe nur noch für die behandlung
von menschen reserviert sein
doch der anhang der eu verordnung lässt
eine hintertür offen im kleingedruckten
heißt es antibiotika die wesentlich für
eine gewährleistung des tirol sind
dürfen weiter eingesetzt werden
wenn ich jetzt höre dass das tier wohl
jetzt als pet hingenommen wird das
öffnet die tür und tor dass bauern und
tierarztes einsetzen können wenn sie
meinen dem tier geht es nicht richtig
gut also wir werden das so nicht
akzeptieren weil es im widerspruch steht
zu dem was wir eigentlich vor zwei
jahren vereinbart haben in den nächsten
wochen wird sich zeigen wer setzt sich
durch eine politik die verbraucher
schützt oder eine industrie die
verdienen möchte
[Musik]